et on conclut ce sky Eco cette édition
spéciale du skyco sur le Big tour de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines avec le
vice-président charge de l'emploi à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Nicolas
Dainville bonjour bonjour et mère de
Laval et mère de la verrière exactement
très très belle événement on a saisi
cette opportunité d'avoir cet événement
du Big tour pour organiser aussi un
forme de l'emploi et donc le greffé sur
cette journée et c'était efficace
instructif et j'ai pu constater moi-même
avec des expériences des jeunes que j'ai
moi-même accompagné dans les dans le
vélodrome qui en plus un endroit assez
extraordinaire à l'approche des JO de
Paris 2024 et j'ai pu voir à quel point
c'était efficace c'est le mot que je
retiendrai alors
on a eu 1500 rendez-vous pour ce job
d'État donc c'est quand même extrêmement
important il y avait 150 entreprises il
y avait quand même près de 5000 offres
d'emploi donc ce sont des chiffres quand
même qui parlent de même et dans des
secteurs très variés à la fois la grande
distribution la cybersécurité
l'animalerie
la haute valeur ajoutée sur les sujets
de défense bref il y en avait pour tous
les âges pour tous les goûts pour tous
les profils donc
je pense que ça a été un bel événement à
la fois pour ceux qui recherchaient des
talents et aussi pour ceux qui
recherchaient une entreprise alors
justement tout à l'heure Bruno Le Maire
le ministre de l'économie est venu
inaugurer le Big tour et justement on en
a profité pour l'interroger sur ces
difficultés qu'on les entreprises à
recruter regardez la première réponse
c'est avoir des formations des
qualifications qui correspondent aux
besoins des entreprises c'est vrai par
exemple dans le secteur industriel on
voit bien que lorsqu'on cherche un
chaudronnier un soudeur parfois un
Seigneur un technicien de maintenance on
a du mal à trouver des compétences dont
on a besoin la deuxième c'est
l'attractivité des métiers on voit bien
quand on dit on cherche un chauffeur de
car il faut se demander pourquoi est-ce
qu'on manque de chauffeur de car c'est
tout simplement parce que si vous
demandez un jeune de venir à 6h du matin
conduire un quart à 8h sa journée
s'arrête il faut qu'il reprenne 18h et
il est payé que sur 25 heures bah
forcément il va vous dire désolé c'est
pas compatible avec ma vie familiale ça
n'est pas suffisamment rentable puis la
troisième réponse c'est évidemment le
salaire toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires
alors on vient d'entendre voilà le
économie Nicolas Dainville il y a des
entreprises qui ferment parce qu'elles
n'arrivent pas à recruter comment 50 ans
en Yvelines 20 palier ce fléau on peut
dire bah écoutez on prend le le taureau
par les cornes on a labellisé des écoles
du numérique pour essayer de répondre à
la problématique d'un grand nombre
d'entreprises qui manquent de talent
dans cette dimension de notamment la
cybersécurité donc on a labellisé des
écoles type popschool au cloch l'UVSQ
qui a une formation pour vraiment
essayer d'améliorer le vivier de talent
dans ce secteur particulier de la
cybersécurité on organise aussi ce qu'on
appelle une Task Force RH donc on essaye
de fédérer tous les DRH des entreprises
du territoire on a près de 17000
entreprises et on essaye avec ce club de
DRH de mieux comprendre leurs besoins
pour essayer à notre tour de mieux y
répondre on a aussi un site internet qui
s'appelle ski emploi.fr est-ce que Y au
singulier.fr qui regroupe une grande
cVTech de plus de 10000 CV et des offres
d'emploi près de 2000 offres d'emplois
pour essayer que ces offres d'emploi du
territoire
soient prises par des gens du territoire
vraiment rapprocher de l'offre et la
demande au niveau local voilà c'est ces
trois exemples très concrets comment
vous expliquer ce phénomène parce que il
fut un temps où on trouvait pas d'emploi
dans les emplois non qualifiés or
aujourd'hui c'est même dans des emplois
très qualifiés qu'on trouve pas voilà de
gens qui comment on explique est-ce que
on parle de démis de grande démission on
parle de grands phénomènes comme ça
est-ce que ça joue est-ce que il y a
d'autres facteurs or ça joue c'est vrai
que les jeunesse d'aujourd'hui d'autres
aspirations on trouve parfois des
problèmes de vocation même dans le
secteur médical
les ingénieurs exactement avec cette
envie de quitter ce monde métropolitain
il y a aussi un effet covid qui joue
mais je pense qu'on a aussi des métiers
qui sont en plein bouleversement qui
évoluent bien plus vite que les écoles
qui forment nos futurs jeunes là j'étais
avec l'école 2600 qui était aussi dans
cette émission avec eux oui révolutionne
sa pédagogie c'est vrai que on a souvent
des pédagogies du passé pour des métiers
qui sont pas encore inventés qui
nécessitent des écoles très flexibles et
là c'est une école qui est gratuite
c'est une école qui s'adapte qui se
finance grâce à la taxe d'apprentissage
grâce à l'alternance donc avec une
pédagogie qui a rien à voir avec celle
des écoles classiques et je pense que
dans ces secteurs il faut être inventif
il faut inventif et il faut que l'État
aussi suivent c'est pas toujours le cas
on rame souvent pour labelliser des
écoles innovantes on peut parler de
cloques ou de pop School qui sont des
formations à distance pour certaines
d'entre elles bref il y a une nouvelle
pédagogie inventée qui pour plaire aux
jeunes et pour répondre à des métiers en
tension qui sont assez variés ça peut
aller des métiers de la cybersécurité
mais même parfois sur des métiers de
service
manque vraiment de profil et puis pour
terminer je dirais qu'on a eu une crise
en quin la lettre K avec cette crise du
covid avec une rupture nette de
l'activité certains secteurs qui sont
partis d'autres qui souffrent encore au
milieu du tourisme notamment mais
d'autres idées et d'autres qui ont bien
décollé métier du numérique mais du
service à la personne métier du médical
qui manque de main d'oeuvre et donc il
faut qu'on prenne la balle au bon et
qu'on saisisse aussi ses opportunités
donc ces secteurs en fort recrutement
la situation de l'emploi dans le bassin
de Saint-Quentin c'est quoi actuellement
écouter je dirais que c'était un un peu
mitigé on a des grands groupes qui ont
quand même
souffert de cette période compliquée
c'est que le Technocentre Renault par
exemple
a rendu quelques quelques mètres carrés
d'activités mais on reste quand même un
des territoires les plus dynamiques de
France donc
on souffre mais on souffle bien moins
que d'autres territoires on a les
secteurs à haute valeur ajoutée je
voyais Thalès encore tout à l'heure avec
la cigarbonate et notre élu à
l'insertion et il y a encore un besoin
énorme d'ingénieur d'alternance sur ce
secteur de de la défense donc on a 17000
entreprises on est dans les présidents
fourgons le rappelle souvent les huit
zones mondial d'innovation on a la
formation on a la proximité avec Paris
on a la notion de campus qui permet à
des groupes de grande taille de
s'implanter on est très très bien
desservi la ligne 18 qui devrait arriver
bientôt on l'espère et puis vous avez
des opportunités aussi les Jeux
olympiques de 2015
qui a un an les JO qui arrivent qui vont
mettre un coup de projecteur incroyable
sur ce territoire on met le paquet aussi
pour la créativité et que ce qui cube
notre incubateur avec la Maison de
l'Entreprise bref on a tout pour réussir
et donc les jeunes qui veulent vraiment
trouver un emploi qui sont parfois
éloignés du secteur de l'emploi on a
aussi la Mission Locale chez le qui
existe donc ce qui est
25 qui est là pour les 16 à 25 ans qui
sont des scolarisés ou qui cherche une
formation c'est ceux qui sont plus loin
de l'emploi mais il y en a mais vraiment
tous les profils et c'est ça qui est une
richesse extraordinaire de ce territoire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc vous
êtes optimiste toujours toujours et je
vous dis président fourgouse parle
toujours d'un territoire béni des dieux
c'est vrai qu'entre les JO entre
le département des Yvelines qui investit
massivement dans dans toutes nos
infrastructures avec l'innovation
d'innovation d'entrepreneuriat
j'ai envie de dire
et puis vous êtes dans un ensemble
qui qui
rayonne en termes d'innovation et
d'entrepreneuriat on a vraiment tout
pour cartonner et cet événement le
prouve c'est-à-dire que le Big tour
c'est 50 ans en Yvelines qui a été
choisi pour la tournée régionale pour
terminer c'est pas rien
extraordinaire c'est pas un hasard et
donc ça prouve à quel point 50 ans en
Yvelines un territoire qui fait parler
de lui et qui rayonne merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Nicolas Dainville Merci à
VOUS vice-président en charge de
l'emploi à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
merci Patrice merci Nicolas c'est génial
le picto
des des entrepreneurs c'est parce que
c'est c'est vrai c'est ce que disait
l'un d'eux c'est d'abord des aventures
humaines c'est ça qui est formidable des
aventures humaines et des aventures
humaines que l'on raconte sur le Sky Eco
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale du skyco sur le Big tour dans
fera d'autres on en repas
du skyco des numéros dans lesquels vous
pouvez découvrir les entrepreneurs et
les acteurs de l'économie 50 chinoise
merci et à bientôt sur tv78
[Musique]